dazwischen möchte stammend willkommen
beim neuen video und ich rege mich
gerade so auf weil ich sie halt einfach
aus wie ein vogel es ist für mich ein
rätsel warum die heute so aussehen wie
sie aussehen und nicht normal aus dem
hyper wahrscheinlich kommt ihr es wieder
um die ecke und sagt diese normales aber
ich bin voll zufrieden gerade naja egal
ist haarig habt ihr auch schon mal
hässlich gedreht auf jeden fall herzlich
willkommen beim ein video und zwar für
heute okay ich weiß vielleicht nicht so
in meiner kreativen phase weil ich
zurzeit an was echt großen dran bin und
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht machst du
einfach so ein video ihr werdet es
wahrscheinlich trotzdem feiern weil ihr
so was irgendwie immer feiert und ich
hoffe es wird auch cool und die
reaktionen darauf wird geil oder halt
lustig und wir kommen sofort auf den
punkt und zwar ist das ja zur zeit von
innen auf youtube diese whatsapp rings
also man schreibt einfach irgendwann an
bei mir ist es heute meine freundin die
es geht um essen glaube ich aber ist mir
egal und nimmt einfach irgendwelche
zitate aus liedern aus deutsche liedern
oder englischen die das ist heute ein
ganz besonderes sie was richtig gut
passt und darauf kann eine geile
reaktion kommen also eine lustige
reaktion und zwar ist es von den lobbys
geweint und gelacht aus dem album
zwilling wenn es doch nicht gekauft habt
euch das vielleicht also müsst ihr nicht
aber
ja egal und der text von diesem mit ist
wirklich perfekt für diesen mutter
bringt es ist perfekt ich hoffe es
klappt ich suche jetzt gleich geile
zitate raus ja auch einigermaßen sinn
ergeben und ich bin mal gespannt auf
ihre reaktion
genau deswegen fangen auch sofort an
wenn ihr sagt er das ist voll geil macht
es auch mal bitte bei deinem bruder oder
seiner mutter wenn ich den das sag ich
jetzt noch nicht bei 15.000 leicht kommt
dann am sonntag die nächste folge davon
dass machen ich hoffe einfach sie kennen
diese worte brings nicht vielleicht hat
das ja ob youtube schon mal gesehen ich
weiß es nicht weil wenn dann ist das
leicht scheiße aber wir fangen einfach
mal an mit folgendem zitat irgendwie
geht mein wlan heute nicht voll komisch
auf dem handy funktioniert das einfach
nicht egal dann mache ich mobiles
netzwerk das ist so typisch alex will
wieder trinken funktionieren 2000 jahre
später das kommt sich sein oder hey du
das ist doch nicht schwer das sind fünf
buchstaben vielleicht ein fenster des
nama das kann doch jetzt nicht sein oder
was soll das sie hat geantwortet was ist
jetzt kommt das macht spaß
sag mal kannst du auch trainer
sag mal kannst du dich noch daran
erinnern jetzt kommt bestimmt einfach so
ran oder so man jetzt antwortet
normalerweise kriege ich immer fest
sofort antwort außer jetzt auch mal so
viel später dass der ex neviges nochmal
so viel später dass er jetzt jeder
gestorben ist und wir einen neuen
einstellen müssen so viel später dass es
dem alten erzähler zurück wo ich denn
jetzt einfach mal ein fragezeichen ist
immer noch aus wie ein vogel
auch man bitte schreibt doch hier wird
sie hat immer noch nicht beantwortet
ich glaub das jedoch nichts mehr ehrlich
sehr geschrieben sie so heißt ich mache
jetzt mal eine sprachnachricht und sagen
hier ist alex harris alex und wer noch
ich muss jetzt kurzem vom thema ab weiß
keiner
ich heiße okay das würdest du niemals
schreiben
und du willst auch niemals so komisch
herr hier ist alex sagen kannst du dich
mal meine stimme ist dass ich meine
stimme alles klar danke
doch ich bin alex okay jetzt habe ich
voll raus
jetzt kommt eine sprachaufnahme ich
wollte eigentlich dass sie sofort panik
dazu helfers bilder denn jetzt von mir
er wird er auf mich zu verarscht und
jetzt kommt er jetzt kommt das nächste
harte sag mal weißt du noch an diesem
abend so sagt man weiß noch an diesem
abend was kann helfen das ist voll
schwermann wieso kriege ich jetzt keine
antwort warum was red ich bin dein
freund sein dass sie sich sie antwortet
okay sagt schrieben ja als ich erst mal
da war jetzt schreibe ich erstmal genau
das ist nicht mein freund grad
was nehmen wir jetzt okay ich habe eine
idee ich muss erstmal noch irgendwo
anders hin führen ich meine den abend
nein warte ich meine vor zwei wochen
also der abend vor zwei wochen etwas ist
dass hier bald werde ich jetzt jetzt
werde ich richtig gemein was ist los
wenn was ist sagt doch einfach und macht
nicht sein ratespiel draus ja heraus
ja ich und du so jetzt jetzt schreibt
jetzt bin ich gespannt ob die schreibt
aber auch unterschreiben schreibt vor
zwei wochen was war denn da da waren wir
gar nicht in deutschland
scheiße da war ich entspannt bin ich
dumm meine vorstrecken
ich bin einfach so dumme meine vor drei
wochen haben alles verloren und nie
nachgedacht schreibt wie frei sich jetzt
auch damit was kann ich denn jetzt
machen
ich suche noch ein krasses zitat wir
haben geweint und wir haben gelacht es
macht irgendwie keinen sinn mehr ich bin
richtig dumm ja ok reicht jetzt weiß ich
mir das nicht glaubt muss ich jetzt
wenigstens ein bisschen aggressiv machen
ich schreibe jetzt einfach mal das ist
kein spaß gerade sagt doch mal deine
meinung dazu
schreibt mir bitte in die kommentare auf
einer skala von eins bis zehn wie
schlecht bin ich wenn zehn das
schlechteste ist hätte deswegen auch jol
und die fragezeichen
auch man ich hab keine lust mehr bomben
stumm das hätte viel besser werden
können egal bei meiner mutter wird das
klappen ich hoffe die sieht nur dieses
video nicht
das ist jetzt voll scheiße mann du bist
so schlicht ist wahrscheinlich der
schlechteste whatsapp bringt auf ganz
youtube aber dann ist wenigstens der
schlechteste boxplay noch ganz youtube
von mir es wäre zwar besser wer ist der
beste
wegen 15.000 likes dann ist irgendwer
das war richtig witzig wird es bei
meiner mutter so richtig krass klappen
also das überlege ich mir dann selbst
instagram könnte mir gerne folgen aber
nicht vergessen dazu verpassen
und hat reiner thies